اديسون دوناسيمنتو اسماه والده بهذا الاسم
تيمنا بالمخترع توماس اديسون لكن اصدقائه
في المدرسه اطلقه عليه بيليه نتيجه عدم
لفظه لاسم الحارس البرازيلي فيليه بشكل
صحيح هذا الفتى النخيل الصغير صنع تاريخا
يصعد تكراره داخل المستطيل الاخضر بفوزه
بثلاثه القاب لكاس العالم وبطل كهذا
بالتاكيد يحمل قصه استثنائيه فهو من اسره
فقيره عاشقه لكره القدم اصيب في صغره
عندما كان لاعبا محليا ورفض النادي الذي
لعب فيه والده وتحمل تكاليف علاجه فاعتزل
وعمل ماسح احذيه ولانه جوهره جذب انتباهها
مكتشفي
الهجاء الى قطاع الناشئين في نادي مدينه
[موسيقى]
هدف في ثلاثا 33 مباراه فقط لاختيفه
النادي العملاق عام 56 عام
1958 واجهه في ايه انت فيولا اعتراضات على
اصطحاب الفتره بيت 17 عاما لخوض مونديال
السويد الا ان بلاي اصبح اصغر هداف ثلاثيه
شخصيه او هاتريك واصغر لاعب وهداف في
المباراه النهائيه في تاريخ كاس العالم